[Music]
in traphouse nose
Oh Danny sound interesting we need a
trap I was just trying to put a little
hood a trap house is it's like a house
that has a lot of hose hey maybe
narcotics drugs
I didn't they trap you in there maybe a
lot of traffic
oh well you work on your trap stick
you'll never guess who submitted this
one painted submitted by Circe herself
oh I watch the whole thing
are you ready I'm [ __ ] we're getting
extra ready by watching you know I just
watched it all again I heard she had a
stunt double for her tits yeah her body
I didn't dig her body was that great
well you just won it was a tip double
well then why did she do use your own
buddy Brooke she got like paid like 2
million per episode I'm so much for 2
million yeah no one gets paid to do it
for $50 yes she's the highest-paid
actress per episode ever
what about friends I thought Jennifer
Aniston was the highest not 2 million in
episode Circe's the highest air like an
episode well probably a long time yeah
yeah game adores like a dad damn movie
in an episode every one minute she
deserves it man she's awesome sources
don't your stunt doubles tits up - no
okay they're fine tits
I hope you're happy with your
40-something your old woman I didn't
like your tits hot jealous I'm wondering
whose titties were they that yeah you
can look it up in the [ __ ] crap can
you imagine if you were if you wanted to
- if they're like they're like oh you
were in great Game of Thrones
tell us what did you do tell us I would
you don't recognize these I had a very
important role I was a Barry I was
Circe's body double I walked around and
everyone saw my did property rehabbers
find a deadly booby trap
during a renovation project maybe a
booby trap huh
well some previous homeowner set up a
booby trap and forgot they left it there
what a [ __ ] paranoid so this takes
place in South West Philadelphia born
and raised that's what I was thinking I
would set up booby traps in my house let
me show you the video to see for
yourself who is it like a big-ass Bulger
that comes down they push a button and
all the stairs go flat wait so this
video is taken by these property
property managers so they're doing like
a rehabbing of this home to the
condemned house it's a big-ass hammer
that comes down how do they know more I
know that's what he just said how do you
know it sounds like all Rocky's yeah
yeah so there's also a bunch of broken
glass lining the bottle glass everywhere
just don't care there's a tripwire that
that triggered that he found out by
accident I don't know he's just flat on
the steps that look like it no yeah so
there was covered this guy like one of
the workers was about to walk up the
steps but then someone stopped on like
wait that looks [ __ ] fishy hold on
and then they looked up and you could
see the upside down crud I would have
never noticed idea there's no way
there's also there was like this wire
like a tripwire that you could see they
were like look at this any single real
estate that talks like that we went to
get some Philly cheesesteaks though all
the workers there spoke like this
I want to go over there I've never been
to whatever yeah my uber driver was just
like that too and like the most typical
thing ever I hop in a over its part like
midnight in Philly and just first thing
he says [ __ ] Tom Brady [ __ ] he's like
they egos we're gonna [ __ ] kill here
we go this be a long-ass ride
well yeah so luckily no one was injured
thank goodness and so now they've been
trying to flip this home but they're
just really careful what is hit every
wall every door to being in pop Zach I
think someone was after him or what how
does he get upstairs in my job dude step
on that one we need him here but he put
it there I know but like he knows not to
on the third step or whatever do still
like right there that's a dumb question
now was a dumb question yeah it might be
a drug house oh yeah maybe it's a trap
me in a trap house or a piece is a big
fan of home alone
that's what it first looked just like it
was scary style though wasn't like funny
cute there might be when we open the
door and the [ __ ] torches the top of
your head over and over he's not letting
go you better let you keep it like that
when you're gonna let your kitty you get
stuck I'm not gonna let you kill like
that what the hell you guys would be
touching hold on my was a prank
I got electrocuted fixing a dryer like
not a washer but the dryer part Oh real
yeah I was trying to fix it and I forgot
to unplug it I was doing something in
the back forgot what I was doing I think
I was changing out the plug so like it
needed like a three prong and I like I
had like a two prong on it or something
so I was changing out the wire on the
back of the dryer but I forgot to unplug
it first I was like unscrewing the thing
from the back and I [ __ ] got electric
- I was like I freaked the [ __ ] out
that's why I hire people I can't do [ __ ]
myself I'm not gonna do that again yeah
that's scary
yeah I got electrocuted a couple of
times in my life but the one I clearly
remember was when I was a little girl I
was like six or seven like that and I
was trying to make coffee on the
stovetop and he and we had a really hell
all the world's make a coffee
[Music]
did you put cinnamon oh hell yeah my mom
does that [ __ ] she's good that is good
we have a really old
what is it thing called as the top of
the stove arranged that's what it is
yeah really old range and so we needed
they had like metal buttons to turn on
the light or like to turn on the fan or
whatever
for some reason I I was like resting my
head my forehead on that metal button
and I got electrocuted I don't know but
I clearly remember that and I was really
what the hell
but it was from I was trying to fix the
lamp and I left it plugged in like you
and then I had a fork so like you know
what that was that's what people could
be - so how's the kid somewhat like this
and then my my for I'm just like locked
up and I threw the floor like crazy that
was it well mine isn't as crazy as
y'all's um so my brother's 10 years
older than me so when he was in high
school him and his homies that live like
in our neighborhood one of them was like
this really brainy kid that like
inventing [ __ ] so he made this box that
shocks people but he would tell people
[ __ ] yeah he would tell people that it's
um he'd be like oh there's like a little
something inside that can you see it and
then you go and you grab the box so they
did that [ __ ] to me and I was like 7 or
something they're like and my brother
[ __ ] dicks I love him now but who's a
[ __ ] dick he's like yeah hold it
there's a little mouse in there so I
held it and I just dropped it that's all
I got electrocute it - that's fine some
kids knew how to do that [ __ ] and what
they told me like you want to get
shocked and I'm like okay I don't like
use the worst [ __ ] in Mexico yeah
they do that on purpose
like be late sometimes they'll be people
walking around with the car battery and
then they'll be like aw do you want a
little boost I'm sorry that's organic
yeah and so like the car battery was
organic you're not consuming it you're
just getting the shock and it wakes you
up so you don't need from battery acid
wait I think we have different ideas or
what's organic I think cocaine is more
industrial thing the definition of
organic what's Princeton like some other
weird [ __ ] if I make meth
yes that was the energy that you're
getting anything they're trying to catch
light yeah if you got that organic yeah
yeah yeah but that's not healthy either
you guys all right okay let's get
technical my bad any moment you said
organic it's all right you guys hung on
to it for too long it was Rory she got
what it meant I'm seeing not consuming
it it's that you held it fried by
electricity I don't trust anything I
didn't say yeah it probably fried some
brain cells along with it I just
remembered when I got electrocuted I was
at this game zenyatta
it was here in the you I get
electrocuted wants you it's been a few
times my brain the oven want all these
so pretty real like I've done the
battery in that hers but it's like what
if nothing just on your tongue it's us
or like anywhere like I probably felt
like even like a little car battery zap
when you're trying to jumpstart but
that's like whatever that's not like
[ __ ] like 10 years but anyway so um
at this concea they had this pole that
they actually decorated which makes me
think like how the [ __ ] did they
decorate this and not get electrocuted
but this pull itself was like it had
like a current or something place shut
it passing by and I was like oh [ __ ] oh
that's [ __ ] dangerous they away from
this bowl or the pod lights on it no I
don't remember I just remember the pole
was decorated and it shocked me cuz
maybe well what I was decorated with and
had like a wire poking oh yeah it was
decorated with like the paper stuff like
people they maybe dinner without
touching you know what kind of pole it
is no I don't remember there was like a
[ __ ] it's like a street light or
something attached it was connected to
an electric fan but that should I felt
like my whole
[Laughter]
and then someone tries to touch you like
their [ __ ] - yeah also knocking with a
piece of wood right no that's what my
mom taught me never get electrocuted get
like get a 2x4 I think you do different
things with a knocking amount rubber
also does not have a current yeah I
don't think knocking someone else
[Laughter]